on récapitule tout vous voulez avoir un
manuel ma coupe lui dire quoi d'abord je
laime s'étaient rencontrés mais j'ai
plein de choses à lui dire je lui dirai
quand je lui parlais rendu malheureux
merci ce ne fut pas la honte ah ouais
franchement aller aller trop tard allô
mon père qui était au miles au soir
emmanuel merci d'être là avec nous on
voulait pas vous déranger c'est le prix
non c'est matthieu delormeau en fait qui
vous aime beaucoup vous êtes son idole
absolue
je sais que vous êtes en pleine campagne
si vous avez fait votre meeting dimanche
à lyon qui hier vous avez les démentis
des choses voilà pousse à la voilà donc
mathieu ont parlé de ça en parler de ce
démenti t matthieu delormeau voulais
vous parler ce que vous connaissez
mathieu de l'envoi emmanuel macron là et
que tu imagines je ne regarde pas
l'émission mais mon entourage me dit que
vous avez perdu les primaires face à le
tuer verdez
c'était serré il y avait 70 ans bat
mathieu l'isi parler du bas bonsoir
emmanuel cépages parce que je peux vous
appeler manuel banon mais manuel
j'aimerais que je vous aime énormément
je voulais vous dire que vraiment vous
avez moderniser la politique vous êtes
vous vous êtes vous vous êtes très
talentueux notre nouveau inédit
politique est ce qu'il est un pionner
type notre nouveau kennedy je me verrai
si je n'ai bonne au journal parlé à
l'époque la personne là je me proposais
sans me vanter de peut-être ne souhaite
pas on ne vous souhaite pas la même
forme je me proposais sans me vanter
peut-être d'être la nouvelle jackie
voilà ils veulent des gars il va pas du
tout non mais doit on pas du tout géré
en plus de respect pour vous j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'on se pare donc je vous
posez peut-être qu'on prenne un verre
dans un hôtel parisien peut-être sud
votre choix commence par un bistrot vous
viendriez avec vos gardes du corps je
viendrai avec les miens c'est donc si
vous avez alors pardon mais c'est un mot
oui je suis que le la dernière canicule
moi aussi c'est les vieilles que je vais
quand même en premier et je vais vous
dire
[Applaudissements]